la corte fermerà lì per margherita
forestan ai canti audio del deserto
miccichè prima legge dice abbiamo
chiesto per prendersi in fondo
durante il video si è sentito molti si
sono messi a ridere perché spesso
osservare quello che fanno le persone
quello che provano è un'esperienza così
forte da portarci ad imitarli oa
simularli oci contagiano e ci si
potrebbe chiedere se però questo è
qualcosa che succede in casi speciali
come quello che abbiamo visto oppure se
piuttosto non sia la norma se di solito
è la psicologia degli altri viene
compresa tramite questi meccanismi di
imitazione e questa in realtà è un'idea
piuttosto antica vedete qua dietro
alcuni filosofi psicologi che avevano
sostenuto che la psicologia è fatta
prevalentemente di simulazione
imitazione empatia simpatia contagio
eccetera
però che cosa ci dicono oggi le
neuroscienze
la scoperta più interessante in questo
ambito è un po paradossale perché non
nasce dal dallo studio delle aree
cognitive del cervello
il pensiero nasce dallo studio del
sistema motorio sistema motoria e quella
parte del nostro cervello che ci stava
per muoverci è fatta di cellule che
quando si attivano determinano il nostro
movimento quindi ci fanno muovere e se
vengono lesionate tra l'altro hanno una
serie di tragiche conseguenze proprio
nella nella produzione del movimento
tuttavia c'è una piccola popolazione di
cellule del sistema nervoso del sistema
motorio che sono diventate famose
appunto col nome di neuroni specchio che
ha un comportamento un po particolare
perché si si attivano quando noi ci
muoviamo essendo appunto parte del
sistema motorio però si attiva anche
quando noi stiamo con le mani in tasca
vediamo qualcun altro che esegue
esattamente la stessa azione quindi il
pensionato che sta prima nota che guarda
gli operai in realtà sto lavorando anche
lui potremmo dire è che cosa servono
queste cose servono hanno una doppia
funzione aprono in un certo senso un
canale bidirezionale fra me e voi tra
voi e gli altri perché replicare
l'azione degli altri da un lato serve
per comprendere
dall'altro serve anche per apprendere
sono due cose quindi da un lato serve
per leggere il vostro comportamento tra
l'altro serve per invece mappare sul mio
sistema motorio quello che voi state
facendo perfezionando i miei programmi
motori quindi una doppia funzione la
prima ve la faccio vedere così facciamo
una specie di piccolo esperimento ora
facciamo finta che io vada a registrare
un singolo neurone mirò dalla vostra
testa
quindi voi tenete le mani in tasca non
vi muovete perché sennò il sistema
motorio chiaramente si attiverà e
osserveremo dei video quindi vedremo
cosa fa un singolo vostro neuroni mirror
durante l'osservazione di quattro
scenette quotidiane ascoltare un neurone
vuol dire ascoltare la sua frequenza
discarica quindi sentirete uno
scoppiettio tanto più scoppietta il
video tanto più il vostro singolo
neurone mi ero si sta attivando quindi
guardiamo il primo video quindi una
scena diciamo quotidiano una persona che
parla di una cosa in questo caso una
mela voi avevate le mani in tasca il
vostro sistema motorio avrebbe dovuto
rimanere silenziosi invece una parte si
è attivata e ha simulato esattamente la
stessa azione questo neurone normalmente
si attiverebbe quando siete voi a
prendere lamela e non quando soltanto
guardate poi siccome sono molto
specifici un'azione anche leggermente
differente come questa non funziona
quindi qua mancava la mela l'azione non
era prendere lamela era qualcosa di
diverso e quindi quello specifico
neuroni mirror in questo caso non si è
attivato altri sicuramente saranno
attivate ma non questo qui che era
tarato sul prendere lamela però la
scoperta curiosa e invece nel terzo
video guardate cosa succede
allora qual è successo voi con gli occhi
non avete visto che la mela veniva presa
però avete capito che sicuramente là
dentro qualcuno stava prendendo una mela
il sistema motorio e in particolare il
sistema mirror era avvertito della cosa
quindi se con le aree visive noi non
abbiamo visto nessun apprensione di mele
tuttavia noi abbiamo compreso che la
dietro avveniva l'apprensione della mia
in questione è il sistema motorio ha
partecipato a questo a questa
comprensione e naturalmente
l'ultimo caso ovviamente la mela non c'è
un'attività del nostro neurone e poco o
nulla quindi il sistema motorio serve
anche per capire le azioni degli altri
non solo per farci fare le nostre azioni
e tra l'altro deficit del sistema mirror
è stato dimostrato che portano un
cattivo processamento delle azioni degli
altri quindi capiamo un po meno bene gli
altri se abbiamo un deficit in questo
sistema
l'altra faccia della medaglia era era
limitazione ora la quale scuote
l'apprendimento dicevamo abbiamo detto
sarà per comprendere e per apprendere e
apprendere per imitazione è un fenomeno
che non ha bisogno di presentazioni di
sappiamo tutti quanto importante per
apprendere da un lato provare noi stessi
e dall'altro vedere gli altri che lo
fanno allora e interessare questa
immagine quadra l'altro l'immagine di
mezzo sono psicologo che negli anni
settanta andare in giro per i reparti
maternità a fare la lingua ai neonati di
benvenuto presumo e scoprendo però che i
bambini già poche ore dalla nascita
saggiamente replicavano rispondevano e
quindi ha dimostrato in realtà che già a
poche ore dalla nascita
noi mettiamo siamo degli imitatori di
naturali ora naturalmente un bambino non
non ancora uno sviluppo corticale e in
particolare di quei sistemi inibitori
che bloccano quest imitazione quindi noi
riusciamo a bloccare
se faccio così adesso voi non mi state
salutando però in realtà una parte
tranne qualcuna però in realtà una parte
del vostro sistema motorio stava
esattamente facendo quello bloccate
l'azione l'azione non viene eseguita per
avere programmato
come dei bambini quindi poi noi
impariamo a bloccarlo ma questo comunque
ci porta un apprendimento quindi
l'antico detto cinese se ascolto
dimentico se vedo ricordo e se faccio
capiscono in realtà è curioso perché
spesso io faccio anche quando
apparentemente non facciamo guardo fare
appunto come il tizio davanti agli
operai di cui si parlava prima
quindi sarà per comprendere e per
apprendere però uno potrebbe dire ma in
realtà questo riduce molto l'idea di
interazione sociale perché noi non ci
limitiamo a capire le azioni degli altri
noi dobbiamo capire le loro azioni
all'interno di un contesto emozionale
sensazioni gesti comunicativi il
linguaggio quindi capiamo tutte queste
cose insieme
e però la cosa interessante negli ultimi
anni in neuroscienze è la scoperta che
contrariamente a quello che vi ho detto
i neuroni mirror non stanno solo nel
sistema motorio ma che l'architettura
del cervello di tutto il cervello
implica la localizzazione di una
moltitudine di meccanismi mirror che
stanno nelle aree motorie replicando e
facendoci simulare le azioni degli altri
nelle aree emozionali facendoci simulare
o evocando in noi le emozioni degli
altri
idem per le sensazioni gesti linguaggio
così via quindi quando noi interagiamo
con gli altri in realtà tantissimi
diciamo meccanismi di imitazione di
simulazione sono in atto in quel momento
e ci portano a punta questo tipo di
condivisione
un esempio un esempio su tutti può
essere quello legato all'area del
cingolo il cingolo allora mentre le aree
motorie sono più o meno a questa altezza
quelle dei neuroni mirror classici del
sistema motorio invece il cingolo e
un'area profonda che sta qua sotto nella
corteccia prefrontale e fa cose tutto
tace differenti da quelle delle aree
motorie naturalmente in parte
sconosciute
si sa che il cingolo affettiva quando
noi per esempio guardiamo fumetti
divertenti comici tipo questo non ci
posso credere
sta arrivando trovare
durante esperienze piacevoli sensoriali
piacevoli come per esempio cosa quanto
mai quotidiana essere massaggiati da una
bomba durante l'effetto placebo e poi in
questa sala si è attivato il no il 5 di
tutti noi proprio fa durante
l'osservazione del video di clinton e
yassin che nel 95 scoppiano a ridere in
conferenza stampa barca il 5 lo si
attiva anche quando noi osserviamo
espressioni positive gente che ride
quindi abbiamo avuto tutti una
collegiale attivazione del 5 del proprio
fa però qual è il filo conduttore di
tutte queste esperienze per riuscire a
scoprirlo ci siamo avvalsi di una
collaborazione per noi fondamentale con
l'ospedale niguarda
poco distante da pasto a milano dove sei
più importante centro europeo di
chirurgia dell'epilessia per riuscire a
a mappare l'epilessia e a curare i
pazienti in questi medici localizzano
dei piccoli elettrodi all'interno del
cervello appunto funzioni di
localizzazione mappaggio funzionale
registrano dei pazienti e stimolano da
questi elettrodi il loro compito è
naturalmente quello di correre pazienti
e ci riescono in maniera eccellente
tuttavia raccolgono una quantità di dati
preziosissimi sul cervello umano che è
altrimenti impossibile riuscire a
raccogliere quindi tramite questa
collaborazione ne abbiamo cercato di
capire cosa succede quando per esempio
viene stimolata quest'area un'area che
si attiva quando noi osserviamo persone
che ridono e ora ve lo faccio vedere
vedrete una paziente con un elettrodo
nel 5 l'elettrodo naturalmente non lo
vedete perché dentro al singolo e la
pace detiene le mani alte viene chiesto
di leggere e poi un certo punto il
medico rilascia una piccola stimolazione
elettrica e questo è quello che succede
ideato da ridere quindi quell'area che
poco fanno adem attivato osservando
clinton e helsinn che scoppiavano a
ridere non è un'area visiva le aree
visive sono tutt'altra parte del
cervello e un'area che se stimolata
produce risata se qualcuno mette un
elettrodo in quest'area ci fa ridere
quindi l'osservazione di quella scena si
è direttamente mappata sulle aree che
controllano la nostra risata quindi
ancora una volta un'imitazione però così
forte da portare ad attivare a far
cedere come se fossero una stimolazione
elettrica del nostro singolo per quello
alcuni di noi sono messi a ridere
durante questa osservazione quindi il
meccanismo mirror funziona abbiamo detto
nelle aree motorie replicando le azioni
ma per esempio nel singolo e
riproducendo e facendoci simulare la
risata di espressioni positive degli
altri quindi un meccanismo complessivo
ora per chiudere che cosa serve o quali
sono i possibili le possibili ricadute
di un meccanismo del genere e sono
tantissimi difficile adesso riassumerle
per cui lo farò così
in un attimo non c'è dubbio che la
scoperta di questo meccanismo abbia
rivoluzionato alle neuroscienze
cognitive
questo è fuori discussione idem per
quello che riguarda alcuni settori della
filosofia abbiamo visto come alcuni
filosofi già sospettavano meccanismi
simili e l'empatia eccetera
i disturbi pervasivi dello sviluppo per
esempio l'autismo ha tra i suoi tratti
caratteristici il disturbo della sfera
sociale allora è chiaro che un nesso
potrebbe esserci in effetti molti studi
stanno scoprendo come deficit di questo
meccanismo possono avere un impatto tra
le caratteristiche del ottismo
addirittura la medicina riabilitativa
sono alcuni studi che mostrano come un
paziente ortopedico immobilizzato possa
beneficiare se oltre alla pratica
riabilitativa a delle sessioni di axn
observation terapie osserva quindi gesti
eccetera
c'è un guadagno studi simili vengono
fatti addirittura sull'ictus dove la
situazione è senz'altro molto più
complessa psicoterapia estetica
psicologia dello sviluppo
l'apprendimento a prendere
uno strumento oppure apprendere le arti
marziali o qualunque altra abilità
sportiva
tutto questo a che fare con il
meccanismo mirò quindi il futuro sarà
divertente